قالت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان وزراء دفاع
روسيا وسوريا وتركيا اتفقوا على تشكيل
لجان المشتركه من مسؤوليه الدفاع
والمخابرات ستبدا اجتماعاتها نهايه الشهر
المقبل في موسكو تعقيبها اجتماعتهم في
انقره ودمشق
وحسب المصادر ذاتها فان اجتماع موسكو اتفق
ايضا على اليه مشتركه لتسهيل عوده
اللاجئين السوريين بعد توفير الارضيه
المناسبه كما ناقش اجتماعه موسكو وتصورا
يضع حدا لوجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شمال سوريا وفتحت طرقات
الدوليه على سماحه للبضائع التركيه
بالمرور عبر الاراضي السوريه
من جهه قال وزير الدفاع التركيه خلص يا
كارن ان بلاده لن تقوم باي عمل ضد
السوريين المقيمين في تركيا او داخل سوريه
واكد اكار خلال اجتماعا مع ضباط اتراك في
مقر رئاسه هيئه الاركان في انقره ان تركيا
قامت بدورها في الحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار
هذه ضمان السلام والاستقرار في منطقتنا
والحفاظ عليه وسنواصل القيام بذلك يؤكد ان
تركيا لن تقوم باي عمل ضد الاخوه السوريين
المقيمين في تركيا او داخل سوريا لم نفعل
شيئا يضر السوريين في تركيا قبل الان ولم
ياتي سلوكا من شانه المس بهم على جميع ان
يعرف هذا ويتصرف وفقا لذلك
هذا هو كان وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود
وقد قال لنا النظام السوري يرغب في عوده
اللاجئين السوريين الى بلادهم واشددها على
ان تتم بشكل ايجابيا مع ضمان سلامه
العائدين
واكد شوشو اوغلو انه سيكون هناك اجتماع
اولي بين وزراء خارجيه تركيه وروسيا
والسوريه للعمل على خريطه طريق قبل
الترتيب للقاء بين قاده هذه الدول
واستبعد في الوقت ذاته عقد هذه اللقاءات
خلال شهريه يناير المقبل كونها تستوجب
تحضيرات وخطوات ملموسه وفقا تعبيرها
من اسطنبول مراسل الجزيره عامر لا في عامر
هل هناك من تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه التوافقات
التي تم الاعلان عنها
مفاجئا للجميع نعم كان هناك توقع للتقارب
تركي سوري لكن ليس بهذه السرعه وليس بهذا
المستوى وبالتالي كان الموضوع مفاجئا
للجميع مفاجئا هنا في تركيا مفاجاه
لسوريين سواء المقيمين هنا وايضا لان صح
وصفهم بحلفاء تركيا من المعارضه السوريه
في الشمال السوري وبالتالي واضح ان ذلك
استوجب رسائل توضيحيه ورسائل طمئنه من
الجانب التركي اقصد هنا التصريحات التي
جاءت على اللسان وزير الدفاع خصوص اكار
اليوم عندما قال باننا لا لم نس- ولا
النسئه في يوم ما الى ما وصفهم باخواتنا
السوريين في تركيا وفي سوريا ايضا وهنا
المقصود طبعا ربما المعارضه السوريه
وفصائل المعارضه السوريه فعلا ان هذه همم
ما يريد الاتراك ان يقولوه هنا خصوصا بعد
الحديث عن همم التوصل او مناقشه اهليه
لاعاده اللاجئين الى النظام الى سوريا هنا
طبعا المقصود وفقا لمصادر في وزاره الدفاع
جمال بان لن يكون هناك تسليم او ترحيل
اجباري للمواطنين السوريين المقيمين هنا
في تركيا المقصود كما قالوا لنا بانهم
يريدون ان يسهلوا هذا الامر
يحسن من الاوضاع في سوريا لتكون هذه
العوده كما وصفوها كريمه وطوعيه كما قالوا
بمعنى انه لن يكون هناك محاكمات لن يكون
هناك ملاحقات قضائيه لهؤلاء تسويه الامور
التوافق على حل سلمي معين يمكن لهؤلاء
السوريين ان يعودوا الى بيوتهم التي كما
قالوا لنا هناك السعي وحديث عن همم اذا
كان هناك قد تمت مصادرتها ان تعود لهؤلاء
السوريين وبالتالي هذا هو هدف تركيا تعلم
ان هذا الموضوع مهم جدا بالنسبه لتركيا
الان لا يمكن ان يخفى على احد تركيا مقبله
على الانتخابات صعبه ومصريه ومعقده
العداله والتنميه هنا مهدد نوعا ما
المعارضه تستخدم هذه الورقه ورقه اللاجئين
بشكل كبير ويريد ان يقلل من اهميه هذه
الورقه في ايديهم وبالتالي هو يريد ان
يعيد نسبه من هؤلاء المواطنين السوريين
الموجودين هنا في تركيا ان اتحدث جماعه عن
نحو اربعه ملايين مواطن سوري هنا وايضا لا
يريد ان يخسر حلفائه في الشمال السوري
ايضا ويريد ان يتقارب وين الجزئيا حتى
الان مع النظام السوري براس الجزيره عامر
همم في متحدثا الينا من اسطنبول شكرا